d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir de ce
variant omicron venus d'afrique du sud
avec solène boisset
japon australie maroc les fermetures de
frontières s'enchaînent suite à la
découverte de cas positifs aux variants
omicron face à ce vent de panique les
pays du g7 se sont réunis en urgence ce
lundi dans un communiqué il estime la
communauté internationale est confrontée
à la menace d'un nouveau variant
hautement transmissible du comique 19
qui nécessite une action urgente les
pays du g7 vont continuer de travailler
en étroite collaboration avec l' oms
pour partager l'information est
surveillé omicron en france huit
personnes ont été identifiées comme
potentiel porteuses de cette nouvelle
mutation et placé en isolement un
chiffre vraisemblablement sous-évalué y
circule bien plus que les huit cas où
les douze cas qui ont été recensés à ce
jour après ce qu on doit craindre qui se
répandent rapidement grâce à ça dépendra
justement de deux des caractéristiques
de ce variant que pour le moment on ne
connaît pas un sa contagiosité et puis
2e botté d'inquiétude ce serait
évidemment s'il avait une résistance aux
vaccins une possible résistance due au
nombre sans précédent de mutation de ce
virus les laboratoires pfizer et bio and
take ont annoncé préparer un potentiel
rappelle spécifique dans un délai de 100
jours l'om est quant à elle parle d'un
risque de contamination très élevé
pour autant aucun décès n'a été rapporté
pour le moment les résultats des
premières études sur le variant omicron
sont attendus dans deux à trois semaines
et on débat autour de l'apparition de ce
variant on va débattre aussi de l'état
de la recherche française dans cette
émission avec mes invités françois
bricaire bonsoir bien jouer vous êtes
infectiologues membre de l'académie de
médecine l ancien chef du service
maladies infectieuses et tropicales à la
pitié salpêtrière fait riqueval tournant
soir bonsoir à vous aussi président de
la fédération hospitalière de france et
maire de fontainebleau mère agir de
fontainebleau géraldine prévost gigan
bonsoir vous êtes psychopathe
praticienne c'est vraiment difficile
une bûche et viale de la sauter ça ira
mieux tout à l'heure merci d'être là où
officie avec nos visions conférence le
professeur eric comme kate
infectiologues à l'hôtel-dieu professeur
de maladies infectieuses et tropicales à
la sorbonne psycho praticienne faut tout
de suite remonter à cheval quand il est
tombé bienvenue matthieu croissandeau
heureux de vous accueillir tous les
lundis et mercredis que sait-on de
mikron j'ai envie de commencer par là
parce que c'est certainement la question
que majorité de nos téléspectateurs se
se pose est peut-être françois bricaire
pourquoi l oms de mahler tu as écouté je
pense que l'isolément de ce nouveau
variant de monde on sait pas encore
énormément de choses mais on en sait
déjà peut-être suffisamment disons pour
avoir quelques craintes et donc
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
relayé cette crainte il ya comme ça a
été et évoqués dans le reportage
beaucoup de mutations dans différents
endroits et certains de ces endroits où
il ya des mutations laisse supposer un
certain nombre de caractéristiques qui
pourraient jean-paul conditionnelle
quand même être préoccupante et quand on
évoque le fait qu' ils pourraient être
produites en semi cible qui pourrait
aussi être entre guillemets résistant
aux anticorps induits par le hac st
c'est parce que il y a des éléments sur
cette analyse du virus qui dit le fond
évoqué évoqué je vois que vous êtes
prudent vous employez beaucoup de
conditionnel fouet mais mais on est un
peu obligé d'aller aussi vite dans les
précautions dans le chalet redonner le
par le ms ou même dans les faits on va y
venir dans les fermetures de frontières
oui je pense que le conditionnel est
souvent nécessaire parce qu'on voit bien
depuis le début de cette pandémie qu'on
se trompe très régulièrement que les
prévisions ne sont valables qu'à très
court terme et encore et par conséquent
vouloir redonner des affirmations
immédiate c'est toujours un petit peu
risqué donc autrement dit même si ce
variant et
potentiellement à risque il faut pas non
plus induire trop de peur
vous comprenez le prince et le principe
de précaution tout simplement qu est en
train de cela depuis depuis la
communication de ms oui je pense que
l'on voit que la manière dont on
communique l'om est d'ailleurs depuis le
début la la pandémie a évolué il s'agit
pas effectivement comme vient de le lien
professeurs de faire peur mais
effectivement il faut être prudent
d'autant plus que ces annonces autour
d'un nouveau variant qu'on ne
soupçonnait pas ya encore une semaine
donc tout ça se passe en temps réel et
ce qui en matière de médecine je ne suis
pas médecin et on sait que la médecine
pour apprécier la la la réalité des
choses a quand même besoin d'un peu de
temps et de recherche
tout ça se précipite un peu mais ça
arrive dans un moment où la france elle
même on aborde une sacrée vague alors
dont on sait pas jusqu'où elle va monter
dont on ne souhaite pas qu'elle montre
oh enfin on est quand même sur une
petite reprise de l'épidémie plus que
sur un moment de r2 de 2,2 à un moment
de tomber alors retomber voilà donc il
faut avoir cette vigilance et il faudra
cette vigilance mais
je pense que omicron sans être mais ça
on a vu contre l'apparition de certains
variants et leur impact
ne serait ce que dans notre pays il
s'est déjà passé quelques semaines voire
quelques mois concernant par exemple
variés anglais fin 2020 donc il faut
regarder tout ça avec évidemment
beaucoup de prudence et ne pas oublier
que c'est maintenant qu'on se prémunit
contre effectivement
le développement ces virus et notamment
cette cinquième vague qui doit plus nous
occuper peut-être que le suivant je ne
sais pas mais en tout cas on doit pas
oublier qu'il ya des urgences maintenant
de vaccination de précaution et c'est
bien sûr on rappellera évidemment ces
principes et rit comme évidemment l'une
des questions qu'on se pose c'est est-ce
que les vaccins existants vont nous
protéger contre ce nouveau variant ça
prend combien de temps pour avoir ce
type de réponse
écoutez je prends que feront ce week-end
à très bien ni sur la piste c'est à dire
qu'il a volontairement utilisé le
conditionnel et je pense que le
conditionnel s'impose ici
indiscutablement parce qu'en fait on n'a
aucune idée de ce qui nous attend avec
ce variant il a un potentiel
effectivement mais la réalité c'est
qu'on sait le parent ni en termes de
pathogénicité ni en termes de
transmissibilité et bien évidemment ni
en termes de protection croisée que ça
soit parlé du fait de l'immunité
vaccinale ou de l'immunité naturelle
puisqu'il ya quand même beaucoup de gens
qui ont été infectés
voilà donc pour l'instant on peut rien
dire la seule chose qu'on peut dire
c'est qu'il vaut mieux avoir la
meilleure protection qui soit au moment
où ce variant ibra samb terrain
c'est-à-dire avoir eu au moins une
troisième injection oui parce que
françois bricaire si si même si le
vaccin est peut-être sera on n'en sait
rien
peut-être moins efficace imaginons que
soit moins efficace construisent variant
c'est quand même mieux d'avoir fait le
rappelle que de ne pas l'avoir fait
incontestable sa cession doit en aucune
façon démobiliser les gens en faveur de
la troisième injection pour ceux qui ont
eu les deux premières et puis j'allais
dire aussi pour ceux qui ont jusqu'à
présent refusé la vaccination de enfin
bien vouloir l'accepter et ils ont
reposé la même question même si j'ai
bien vu que here i come été prudents ils
voulaient pas exactement répondre mais
c'est quoi c'est une question de jours
de semaines pour savoir si les vaccins
existants aujourd'hui seront efficaces
contreuse maria de bain il faut le il
faut comme vous l'avez évoqué le temps
nécessaire de l'observation de ce qui se
passe on est loin bien loin même si on
arrive dans des laboratoires à anticiper
en travaillant avec une souche virale et
les sérums d'un certain nombre de
personnes de voir s'il ya une bonne
protection au contraire il ya une perte
de protection il faut quand même un
minimum de quelques semaines donc je
crois je là encore sans vouloir donner
des chiffres trop précis mais il faut
encore trois semaines pour avoir des
précisions sur ce que peut donner ce
type de variants la géraldine prévost
gigan le ce type de nouvelles comment
comment elle est perçue cette impression
peut-être de repartir de repartir en
arrière c'est ça ce que vous avez en
tête est ce que nous on a tous en tête
que vous ressentez auprès de vos
passions absolument ce que j'observe
c'est que il ya une usure de cette
répétition et en plus de ça c'est à
chaque fois nouveau c'est à dire que on
n'a pas le temps les personnes n'ont pas
le temps de s'installer dans cette
nouveauté de s'adapter à la situation
que au bout de quelques mois
va nouveau une situation nouvelle est
donc là ce que nous vivons actuellement
réveille à nouveau le stress que les
personnes ont pu ressentir en mars 2020
et l'accumulation la répétition
l'impression que les personnes ont que
ça ne s'arrêtera jamais j'entends des
patients me dire ça va être comme ça
tout le temps ne pourra plus jamais
s'approcher on ne pourra plus jamais se
serrer la main on ne pourra plus jamais
faire la bise donc il ya une projection
dans l'avenir qui est plutôt négative
qui n'est pas très chaleureuse et qui
met dans des conditions psychologiques
sous stress permanent sans qu'on s'en
rende compte c'est un stress l'attend
permanent puisque il ya sans arrêt du
changement donc ça vient solliciter chez
nous une réadaptation constante et donc
en effet la répétition l'accumulation on
ne sait pas où on va voilà et les
informations arrivent et semble pour
certaines personnes ne pas suffire comme
s'il fallait plus de précisions
quand comment combien et ormes sait pas
on a les informations au fur et à mesure
et puisque j'ai entendu aussi c'est
cette difficulté un jour c'est ça un
autre jour c'est ici et du coup les
personnes sont dans cette cyber nation
dans l'année et n'arrive plus à suivre
et c'est là qu'il y à la perte de
confiance aussi c'est vraiment
intéressant ce que vous dites parce que
mathieu cécé ça questionne à la fois la
parole scientifique et la parole
publique c'était incertitudes qui nous
poursuit candidat est saisie depuis deux
ans que cette grosse fatigue et touche
aussi lüthi fait et le gouvernement ont
rappelé a fait depuis mars 2020 qui
n'avance pas au juge aimé qu'ils
avancent deux ans elle mesure des
découvertes scientifiques en prenant des
mesures pour le coût de protection qui
sont pas les mêmes avec le temps et
surtout ils pensaient que ce chapitre qu
il était derrière lui d'une certaine
façon et qu'on pouvait enfin renouer
avec la traditionnelle campagne
présidentielle en tout cas avec les
traditionnelles thème de la vie
politique
j'ai cette grosse fatigue touche au
gouvernement et on voit que du coup
alors que même qu'il y avait des
premières mesures qui avaient été prises
dans le cadre de cette recrudescence et
de la cinquième vague là ça va jouer
encore un effet d'accélérateur par
principe de précaution c'est à dire que
on en est à prendre des mesures qu'on ne
prenait pas encore il ya quelques et
quelques mois de cela on voit dans
d'autres pays à la fermeture des
frontières tout de suite après ce qu'il
faut paniquer moi je me souviens
personnellement mais c'est juste pas du
tout un scientifique qu'on avait très
peur du variant dix brésiliens et d'un
premier variante dit sud africain
qui prospérait sur sur la planète au
printemps et qui n'ont jamais vraiment
pénétré en france en tout cas jamais
vraiment pu prendre l'ascendant sur le
variant le variant existant à l'époque
c'est une possibilité ça oui c'est aussi
pour ça je vais le prévisionnel on l'a
vu en matière de co vide c'est
extrêmement court même les
épidémiologistes qui essaient de
modéliser construire des des éléments
pour dire que ça va se passer toute
cette forme ou sous une autre se varions
là va monter ça va se passer dans tel
pays telle façon déjà reconnaissent
maintenant que en général c'est faux et
que par conséquent à moins de quelques
jours il est bien difficile de de faire
du prévisionnel satisfaisant tout vous
vous avez raison c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas aller vers la panique faut être
vigilant il faut être très attentif
lancer tous les éléments scientifiques
qui sont nécessaires pour connaître ce
virus pour savoir ce qui est susceptible
de faire et puis éventuellement et c'est
ce que font déjà les laboratoires
fabriquant les vaccins envisagé
d'adapter le vaccin aux nouveaux
variants et oeri comme je disais
l'impression d'un combat sans fin mais
on est quand même mieux armé aujourd'hui
qu'il ya deux ans
d'abord je pense qu'il faut quand même
insister sur les bonnes nouvelles
d'abord le taux de vaccination ensuite
l'arrivée prochaine d'antiviraux la
possibilité d'adapter les vaccins aux
sources qui circulent
honnêtement je pense qu'il ya aucune
raison de s'inquiéter outre mesure en
plus on ne sait absolument rien de ce
variant un abaissement fort ne sait pas
grand chose en tout cas au niveau de la
pathogénicité de la transmissibilité on
a déjà eu des variantes pour inquiéter
beaucoup les médias et qui finalement
sont retombées comme l'a dit notre
interlocuteur
tout à l'heure il a eu raison de le
rappeler invariants sud-africain
lorgnant brésilien on en a parlé dans
les médias pendant des jours et des
jours et finalement il s'est rien passé
donc là effectivement il ya quelques
sources d'inquiétude de virologie parce
que ce virus à bord communication
épidémiologie parce que ce qui se passe
dans l'état sud africain
où il ya la ville de pretoria
johannesburg doit être surveillé
attentivement mais pour l'instant
on est plutôt dans l'excès de précaution
je pense
oui alors c'est ça pose la question
notamment de la décision de fermeture
des frontières propose à une première
réaction celle de clément bonne le
secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes était sur france inter ce
matin a toujours essayé d'avoir un
dispositif proportionnée et surtout on
essaie d'avoir un dispositif coordonné
pas parce que c'est bien par principe
d'avoir une coordination européenne mais
parce que si comme on l'a fait dès
vendredi on suspend les vols en france
mais que nos partenaires européens ne le
font pas vous avez des contournements
des gens qui arrivent dans un autre pays
européen puis qui peuvent rejoindre la
france en europe je le redis nous
n'avons jamais fermé complètement les
frontières parce que c'est notre espace
de vie pas seulement de tourisme mais il
ya des travailleurs frontaliers par
exemple qu'on besoin chaque matin ce
matin il y en a ceux qui nous écoutent
qui vont au luxembourg en allemagne en
belgique donc on va pas fermer les
frontières européennes
c'est oui c'est amusant parce qu'on voit
quand même que là-dessus la position de
l'exécutif a beaucoup varié avec le
temps au départ il n'était pas question
de fermer les frontières je parle du
printemps 2020 parce que les prisons
vaincre on disait le virus s'arrête pas
aux ne connaît pas de frontières il
s'arrête pas aux frontières et peut-être
ici parce que c'était ce que marine le
pen avec la mer
je vais dire elle le réclamait à
l'époque et ça ça a beaucoup varié avec
le temps on l'a vu ce printemps dernier
et puis là on voit tout de suite le
premier réflexe des européens c'est à
dire comment on peut commencer peux
essayer de se protéger avec cette
vieille méthode que j'allais dire
moyenâgeuse comme le confinement où on
ferme et on se protège alors justement
on va voir avec cantat calmet bonsoir
quant à eux rejoignez nous de quels sont
les pays qui ont fermé les frontières
ont déjà fermé les frontières oui c'est
un sujet intéressant on a voulu
effectivement commencer par ceux qui ont
eu bien les plus grandes restrictions en
terme est bien de fermeture des
frontières des frontières et les quatre
pays ont déjà choisi des restrictions
forte on pense au japon seulement trois
semaines après avoir assoupli les règles
en vigueur dès demain toute nouvelle
entrée des ressortissants étrangers est
interdite même chose pour l'australie
qui devait rouvrir ses frontières aux
étudiants et aux travailleurs et
qualifiés qui suspend cette décision le
maroc suspend les vols en provenance de
l'étranger pour deux semaines avec des
rapatriements au cas par cas négocier
avec les ambassades enfin israël à
verrouiller ses frontières dès samedi
elle n'avait pourtant été rouverte que
le 1er novembre dernier après 18 mois de
fermeture thomas et ce soir enfin on a
appris que la tunisie fermer ses
frontières aux non résidents qui ne sont
pas vaccinés et alors qu'en est-il en
europe et on est clément bonin instant
tu es bien depuis vendredi la commission
européenne a déjà proposé de suspendre
les liaisons aériennes en provenance
d'afrique australe ursula von der leyen
l'a twitté un on le voit dans ce message
la france ainsi que 26 autres pays de
l'union européenne sont en train de le
mettre en place progressivement on a eu
la commission européenne qui nous parle
de 12 pays qui sont déjà en train de
mettre des restrictions pour les
voyageurs notamment avec de l'isolément
pour les personnes qui sont qu'à
contacter de ce variant et même si elles
sont vaccinés en grande bretagne on a
remis en place des tests pcr deux jours
après votre entrée sur le territoire
avec un isolement de rigueur dans la
tente du résultat enfin je voulais
mentionner le fait que l'afrique du sud
et les autres pays qui sont cette
afrique australe eh bien ils ont exigé
avec le soutient l'organisation mondiale
de la santé la levée immédiate je cite
et urgente de ces mesures qu'elle juge
dépourvu de justification scientifique
merci beaucoup merci quand un port pour
toutes ces précisions frédéric valletoux
est-ce qu'il faut forcément fermer les
frontières et c'est difficile moi
j'entends les
à vider des deuxième spéciale qui sont
avec nous ce soir qui sont à la fois
prudents mais qui en même temps disent
peut-être qu'il faut pas s'affoler
inutilement je pense qu'il est beaucoup
trop tôt pour le dire de manière
définitive qu'il faudrait prendre telle
ou telle mesure mais l'ademe je vois
qu'il ya une réunion entière c'est bien
sûr il ya une réunion du oui et de toute
façon comme le disait clément bonne si
il y à un seul pays notamment l'europe
qui ferme ses frontières ça n'aura pas
beaucoup d'efficacité alors il ya sans
doute des concertations qui vont avoir
lieu au niveau des états une réunion du
g7 qui a été provoqué dans la journée
pour les prochains jours j'imagine qu'au
niveau européen ça va aussi discuter la
réponse elle doit être effectivement
coordonnées mais elle doit se faire
aussi à l'appui de des conclusions
scientifiques et de ce que vont dire les
autorités scientifiques internationales
des différents pays européenne peut-être
à partir des données qui vont être
accueillies et ça pour l'instant
personne n'a donc on peut céder à
l'affolement et tout d'un coup remettre
des sacs de sable aux frontières et est
remonté pour le vie mais il n'est pas
évident que d'abord ce soit justifié on
sais pas peut-être peut-être pas et il
est pas évident aussi que ce soit
aujourd'hui les mesure la plus efficace
ce qui est vrai aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
faut pas oublier il faut pas que ce
variant nous qui émergent dont on parle
dont on ne sait pas très bien ni ce
qu'il est dit jusqu'où il va nous
concerner il faut pas oublier qu'on est
quand même dans une aussi dans une
course contre la montre à un moment où
l'épidémie et repas et qu'il faut
accélérer la troisième dose la première
dose pour les quelques millions de
français qui ne sont pas encore allés
vers la vaccination il faut continuer à
avoir comme objectif de préserver les
lignes hospitalière il faut veiller
effectivement à passer l'hiver manière
à la plus confortable possible c'est à
dire en ayant le maximum de protection
je pense que c'est ça et et puis on
verra au fur et à mesure de ce que nous
diront les premières enquêtes
épidémiologiques de ce nouveau variant
si effectivement dans les semaines qui
viennent y a pas de nouveaux dispositifs
de protection à mettre en oeuvre sur
pour diminuer la mobilité puisque tout
ça en fait c'est une affaire de mobilité
c'est la mobilité internationale qui
amène la propagation qui l'a renforcée
mathieu disait c'est un peu moyen âgeux
le continent oui oui vous verrez comme
le quotient et rico mais ce que ces
sortes de gestes barrières pour vous la
fermeture des frontières comment vous
vous évaluer l'efficacité notamment la
le fait de deux fermes et les arrivées
en provenance d'afrique australe
ces gestes barrières suprême
le véritable geste barrière je me
rappelle c'est bien vrai insisté
là-dessus à l'occasion de bonnes
questions c'est le port du masque entre
autres limites et les poignées de mains
des bisous n'oubliez pas faut pas
oublier les fondamentaux je pense qu'il
est important de rappeler qu'on est dans
la cinquième vague effectivement comme
l'affirment ses vannes tout parce qu'on
parle de quelque chose à venir qui ne
viendra peut-être pas le darian owni
crohn mais on parle pas beaucoup on ne
parle plus en tout cas la cinquième
vague quand on est en train de se
prendre de plein fouet
donc je pense que c'est plutôt là dessus
qu'il faudra insister
parce que vous vous le ressentez à
l'hôpital et est ce que vous avez la
crainte finalement d'une sorte de chat
pas comment dire ça de cumul ah bah il
ya un effet cumulatif salaires cumulatif
à la fois parce que l'hiver ait jamais
eu une période pésident les hôpitaux
avec les épidémies hivernales comme on
dit mais c'est aussi parce que c'est
justement c'est la cinquième vague c'est
la cinquième fois qu'on voit remonter
l'épidémie donc il ya un effet de
lassitude qui fait que la digue va avoir
plus de mal à résister et à chaque pic
on va passer si tenté qu'il doyen il
doit bien y avoir de futures elle a dit
être de plus en plus fragilisé enfin on
a ce débat depuis deux mois sur le
nombre de lits fermés à l'hôpital parce
qu'ils manquent des soignants on a ce
débat sur la tva la la la fatigue qui
s'est installée dans les équipes
hospitalières c'est sûr qu'à chaque fois
que que quand il ya une vague qui la
fera un peu la digue se fragilise donc
ça tiendra bien sûr mais la question
c'est que ça tiendra sur à une
institution qui elle n'a pas ménagé sa
peine est aujourd'hui oui et fragilisé
par rapport à ce qui était là sa vigueur
lors des premières vagues donc oui il ya
une inquiétude bien sûr il ya une
lassitude il ya une inquiétude qui gagne
aujourd'hui les services hospitaliers
ils feront face mais ce sera chaque
vague est plus difficile à fermer les
frontières c'est assez une sorte de
repli sur soi est ce que vous ressentez
vous aussi géraldine prévost gillon ce
réflexe chez finalement aux patients -
sortir se replier sur un espace censé
les protéger parce qu'attention la
contamination elle peut avoir lieu en
famille tout dépend de l'état anxieux
initial en fait en fonction de l'état
psychologique des personnes suivant ce
qu'elle traverse dans leurs vies déjà
leur vie à elle s'il ya une dose de
stress qui est déjà bien présente et
bien ça va être plus compliqué parce que
c'est une dose de stress supplémentaire
cet environnement ce collectif est donc
en fonction de l'état interne il peut y
avoir des mécanismes de protection ou en
effet psychologique ou en effet il va y
avoir physiquement un retrait un
isolement d'autres personnes donc là
c'est la surprotection et d'autres
personnes vont être plutôt dans le déni
non non non
on est en train de monter tout ça en
neige ça va pas être si si grave donc
c'est aussi une forme de protection
psychologique pour pouvoir garder
l'équilibré donc ce qui est important
c'est que les personnes puissent parler
à des professionnels pour prendre
conscience de ce qu'elle utilise en fait
comme mécanisme naturel que nous avons
tous le repli ou le déni et de pouvoir
dépasser cela et trouver un équilibre
qui soit juste pour garder justement un
équilibre de vie un équilibre émotionnel
et aussi prendre du recul sur ce qu'il
se passe parce que c'est ces sauts flot
d'informations que nous avons et elle
est nécessaire cette information mais
certaines personnes n'arrivent pas à
filtrer en fait à garder l'essentiel ce
qui est important pour se préparer
éventuellement pour la suite il ya des
personnes qui prennent ça comme comme
une vague d'informations tout comme la
cinquième vague et qui ne peuvent pas
filtré en fait et donc de parler à son
médecin généraliste de parler aux
professionnels peut aider ces personnes
à créer le filtre qui qu'elles n'ont pas
pour pouvoir retrouver un équilibre et
tracer leur route dans ce stress
collectif on y est tous et on peut
trouver des moyens différents en
fonction de chacun pour pouvoir
continuer à vivre de toute façon parce
que c'est important alors quand quentin
qu'elle m'ait parlé de la réaction de
l'afrique du sud je vous propose
d'écouter la présidente des médecins sud
africain elle met en garde regardez
les réactions précipitées en particulier
celle du royaume uni qui ont suivi
l'annoncé risque à l'avenir j'en suis
sûr au
web de rendre les scientifiques et les
pays moins transparents et cela pourrait
mener à la catastrophe
c'est une dimension intéressante
françois bricaire que elle laisse
entendre que nous pourrons risque de
voir des pays qui communiquerait plus ou
moins sur l'apparition d'un nouveau
variant faut pas se retrouver au banc de
la communauté parce que finalement c'est
comme ça m'était nous dit-on du côté des
de l'afrique australe les vols sont les
seuls s'enfermer ou est ce que je veux
dire mais c'est effectivement une
une réaction dangereuse que de vouloir
cacher de l'information ça se retourne
en général toujours contre ce qu'ont
voulu cacher en d'autres termes je crois
que les gens comprennent très bien la
transparence d'une part et deuxièmement
le fait qu'on ne sache pas le ce qui est
inadmissible c'est de dire des choses
alors qu'elles ne sont pas démontrés et
en revanche si on ne sait pas on ne sait
pas et on peut le valoriser de façon
positive jusqu'à présent et rit comme il
ya eu il commence à marcher il ya une
coopération
internationale les informations
circulent entre entre scientifiques
oui les informations circulent très très
bien cet exemple d'ailleurs est
l'exemple falco vie d'adam montrer la
vitesse à laquelle circuler
l'information la vitesse à laquelle se
transporte
à se donner les résultats se
transmettait le les résultats c'est ça
qui a permis d'arriver à un vaccin
d'ailleurs aussi rapidement en même
temps que les moyens financiers qui
était une dent donc bien et vit à un
rythme bien évidemment là la formation
circuler et c'est bien qu'elle circule
juste une chose qu'on peut être allez
dire ça aux chinois quand même parce que
ce que j'avais dit le début de la
pandémie a quand même montré une opacité
totale ou un mensonge d'état la part de
la part de la chine qui a fait prendre
au monde une forme de retard les chocs
la question que ça pose c'est peut-être
que la priorité c'est de vacciner le
monde entier alors ça paraît un peu
vaine benoît de dire ça comme ça mais
parce que on peut se protéger on peut se
laver les mains on peut s'enfermer chez
soi on peut fermer les frontières si on
laisse dans le monde entier des poches
non vaccinés qui vont permettre à de
nouveaux variants de se développer on ne
cessera d'être confronté des nouvelles
vagues alors c'est ce que c'est ce que
disait ce matin sur rtl yannick jadot le
candidat europe écologie verts il était
d'abord agacé par le nom de ce variant
et vous allez voir la logique de sa
démonstration on parle du variant au
micro personne ne comprend rien il faut
arrêter avec ces lettres totalement
débile que personne ne comprend on a un
variant sud africain on a eu le variant
brésilien on a eu le variant indiens
jeudi pourquoi pas pour stigmatiser des
pays mais pour rappeler une réalité nous
ne sortirons pas de cette pandémie tant
que le monde ne sera pas vaccinés jusque
là aussi ça fait un an qu'on se bat pour
la levée des brevets l'ailé fiant
pharmaceutique près de 50 milliards de
bénéfices 50 milliards de bénéfices on
est en train de s'installer dans une
pandémie où on va aller se faire
vacciner tous les ans tous les six mois
ou tous les ans 7e un nom qu'on laisse
les mauvais et on vaccine là le reste du
monde lever les brevets vacciner le
reste du monde françois bricaire alors
le lever les brevets ça c'est quelque
chose qui échappe à mes conseillers une
connaissance et mes capacités mais en
revanche vacciner le monde c'est
absolument indispensable
et effectivement ça fait déjà un bout de
temps qu'on essaie de le faire valoir si
on veut éviter
l'apparition de variants dans le monde
il faut que on arrête la circulation du
virus au maximum donc autrement dit à
côté des pays qui en ont les moyens et
qui se vaccinent et fort heureusement il
faut donner aux pays qui ont des
difficultés à se vacciner les moyens de
se vacciner en quantité d'eau suffisante
en distribution des doses de façon à ce
que les gens puissent être approché se
faire vacciner etc et si on n'aboutit
pas cette mondialisation on risque de
traîner encore avec ces variants qui
apparaissent parce que le virus continue
à circuler voilà je vous aussi vous
permettez je voulais revenir les chinois
qui ne donne pas d'information non tire
pas loire et on voit bien que
les doutes qui sont un style est
régulièrement vis-à-vis de l'origine du
virus contre bien que on a intérêt à
faire des recherches haddock et à
diffuser la bonne information sur la
levée quand même dû du brevet
valletoux il ya des enjeux économiques
qui sont évidemment majeurs qui sont
très lourds mais peut-être que pour
obtenir ce que vous réclamez vous aussi
c'est à dire une vaccination massive
notamment des pays les plus pauvres est
ce qu'il ya une autre solution que lever
les bras
il est une solution déjà de de permettre
aux pays concernés les moins dotées on
va dire d'avoir effectivement des
vaccins des vaccins en masse après la
levée des brevets mais aussi enfin c'est
un sujet qui est qui et qui est
compliqué dans lequel j'ai aucune aucune
compétence ce qui est vrai c'est que
le raisonnement il doit être mondiale et
si l'om est n'a pas la capacité
effectivement de fournit enfin via l'om
est enfin j'veux dire si l'homme les
nations du monde n'ont pas la capacité à
doter les pays effectivement qui sont
les moins bien ou la couverture
vaccinale est la plus faible qui ont le
moins accès au vaccin
sans doute c'est une question qu'il
faudra peut-être se se poser manière
avec steam en tout à fait responsable si
on ne produit pas les vaccins
nécessaires même manière qu'il faudra
peut-être aussi se poser la question à
nouveau de la vaccination obligatoire
dans tel ou tel pays on voit qu'il ya
quand même quelques pays ils sont rares
pour l'instant je pense à l'autriche
mais qui rentre sur cette voie là il y
en a d'autres qui réfléchissent de
manière victimes en plus accentuée c'est
aussi une manière de freiner c'est à
dire si vous n'autorisez sur votre
territoire que des gens qui ont
une couverture vaccinale c'est une autre
parce que vous même vous avez vis-à-vis
de votre population vous êtes allé dans
cette voie là c'est une autre manière de
effectivement de répondre en tout cas de
bloquer la circulation du virus et eric
comme la durée de vie d'un virus alors
c'est pas moi j'avais cru comprendre que
c'étaient deux peut-être trois ans est
ce que est ce que là on est vraiment
dans un cas de figure qui est totalement
nouveau pour vous aussi
non j'ai déjà dit qu'elle est un
précédent historique
qui est l'épidémie de coronavirus hausse
et 43 qui a eu lieu en 1890 je dis bien
1890 pour lequel on a pas mal de données
cliniques épidémiologiques le à l'époque
le virus avec lequel on vit toujours
aujourd'hui qui s'est installée
l'épidémie a duré cinq ans avant que ça
devienne à un stade endémique ça a
dépendu des pays évidemment à l'époque
n'avait pas de vaccin il n'y avait pas
de confinement donc c'est l'histoire
naturelle de cette épidémie cinq ans et
là je pense qu'avec le vaccin ça dure un
an longtemps et par ailleurs l'immunité
naturelle collective je peux vous dire
en afrique ils ont pas confiné ont très
peu ils n'ont pas fermer les frontières
ou très peu le virus à circuler
largement il n'ya pas lui de catastrophe
énorme parce que la pyramide des âges
enfin c'est des gens jeunes sans corps
c'est encore une comorbidité sans eux
sans de problème majeur de visiter ou le
diabète le virus a largement circulé et
bien évidemment faut rassurer les gens
on va finir par arriver à l'immunité
politique que ce soit naturellement ou
avec le vaccin ou le plus probable avec
les deux est en fait ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que on peut attraper le virus
effectivement probablement plusieurs
fois de suite encore moins deux ou trois
fois de suite mais qu'à chaque fois
c'est moins grave et qu'à un moment on
sera totalement immunisés je pense c'est
comme ça que je vois les choses un mot à
mot politique peut-être médias puisque
la durée de vie de cette épidémie ça
pose quand même des questions sur les
libertés publiques g / sur le quoi qu'il
en coûte enfin il y aurait un certain
monsieur juste un mot d'abord sur les
brevets le lever les brevets ça peut
être un enjeu de géopolitique
internationale mais il ya aussi une
question très concrète de fabrication et
je dois m'en souvenir nanofiltration à
fabriquer pour pfizer 2 quand ils ont
pris la décision début janvier il avait
de mémoire un site qu'ils étaient
capables de faire rapidement un vaccin à
moins 70 degrés fasse pas y'a pas des
usines partout dans le monde prête à
fabriquer des vaccins arn messager à des
températures aussi froides après vous
avez vous avez raison de dire que la
pandémie et bouscule toute la vie
sociale et donc la vie politique
on est en état d'urgence on a été en
état d'urgence terroristes depuis 2015
jusqu'à
2017 et puis ensuite il ya eu des lois
et on est de passer en état d'urgence
sanitaire
dans la foulée et donc cher c'est vrai
que les libertés publiques elles sont
rognées mais il ya il faut le
reconnaître en tout cas quand on regarde
les enquêtes d'opinion une forme
d'acceptation sociale de 7 de ses
libertés publiques un peu contrainte on
a vu les manifestations contre le pass
annie terre on voit ici et là des gens
des gens qui se heurte à la volonté des
pouvoirs publics mais il ya quand même
une acceptation sociale parce que c'est
à peu près la seule solution alors c'est
vrai que c'est pas bon c'est pas bon
parce que petit à petit on accepte on a
accepté de remplir soi-même des feuilles
avant de sortir on accepte de devoir
montrer d'aidé
aider nos portables sanitaire m peuvent
nous tracer alors on nous dit que tout
ça n'est pas gardée bien sûr voilà on
accepte on accepte beaucoup de choses au
nom de cet impératif sanitaire est alors
heureusement que le parlement s'en
saisit on a bien vu ici au sénat à alger
avec heureusement qu'on a quand même un
pouvoir législatif qui joue son rôle au
moins de contrôle avec l'émission
enquête parlementaire ou sinon de
contre-pouvoir en refusant quand il ne
peut de prolonger et même si l'assemblée
a évidemment prolonger le pas salutaire
mais on voit bien que ça perturbe la vie
démocratique et alors je vous dis pas si
ça va si on a affaire une cinquième
vague monstrueuse dans les mois qui
viennent on est en pleine campagne
présidentielle qu'est ce qui va se
passer pour les meetings qu'est ce qui
va se passer pour le traditionnel porte
à porte qu'est ce qui va se passer pour
des choses toutes simples comme la
distribution de tracts sur les marchés
on risque dans ce cas-là de vision de
campagne électorale présidentielle
commandée véhicule est là la question se
pose dans quelques jours puisque début
décembre il ya déjà plusieurs meetings
importants qui sont qui sont prévues
vrai qu'on termine ce débat autour de la
de l'état de la recherche française avec
ses citations du mathématicien cédric
villani ce qu'il dit dans un article de
libération publié à deux semaines la
science française ressort abîmée par la
crise est ce que vous êtes aussi
pessimistes aussi négatif françois
bricaire est ce que on à mon sens bien
remarqué c'est que pour ce qui concerne
la france les
investissements qui avaient été faits au
point de vue financier se révèle
insuffisant pour qu'on soit en mesure de
répondre immédiatement à ce type de
catastrophe c'est à dire que je
cherchais un vaccin c'est onéreux
chercher un vaccin c'est difficile et
que si on n'y est pas préparé d'avancé
si on n'a pas mis les investissements
nécessaires sur le plan financier pour
le faire on prend du retard c'est
essentiellement ce qui pour moi j'avais
constaté mais c'est la raison pour
laquelle on voit bien que dans le pays
que le nôtre qui était en tête dans le
monde en matière de vaccination et bien
on a reculé et donc
le monsieur gilani a probablement raison
de dire qu'on a été abîmée alors ça doit
inciter nos politiques à revoir la façon
de procéder eric comme votre réaction
sur ce même thème ce que vous diriez la
même chose oui malheureusement je pense
la même chose que je pense et briquets
c'est dingue vigani mais pour moi ça
date pas d'hier quoi c'est juste le
comique arrive et
les problèmes de la science en plus avec
une exposition médiatique
national et international de l'équipe
marseillaise sur la lequel j'ai pas
revenir mais qui a fait énormément de
tort à la science française
oui mais c'est pas c'est pas à cause
d'eux du professeur à ou qu'on n'a pas
trouvé de vaccins
non je suis pas uniquement allusion aux
vaccins solution à tout ce cirque
finalement quand on regarde les grands
pulls les grandes re enfin quand on
regarde ce qui a été publié de
significatif sur le colis de que ça soit
en termes épidémiologique via une
astique
pronostics préventif ou autres bas
quasiment tout vient de l'étranger les
français ne se sont pas illustrés
par de grandes devant résultat un mot
là-dessus falek valletoux sur le fait
qu'on soit finalement absent delà de
cette course au vaccin enfin les deux
constats les qui convergent
effectivement sont claires et illustre
effectivement la situation qu'est-ce
qu'on gardera sur le plan scientifique
de la période à ce jour en tout cas
effectivement la sens le fait que la
france n'a pas su développer des vaccins
- d'une part et puis deuxièmement
effectivement que le le professeur out a
tenu la dragée haute aux débats pendant
des mois et des mois qu'il a fallu voilà
à certains n'ont effectivement de contre
arguments pour montrer que tout ça était
était floue quoi et tu étais pas
scientifique mais mai sur la grande
misère de la recherche française on n'a
pas le sentiment qu'ils aient un essai
pas eu d'électrochoc la fédé décision
politique majeure qui est qu'il soit pas
un plan de relance qui investit beaucoup
sur le secteur de la santé tout ça le
problème c'est que c'est comme les tags
l'hôpital à on constate aujourd'hui une
situation qui était ancienne écurie
qu'on mettra plusieurs années à relever
pour la science c'est la même chose et
si les volailles d'ailleurs une relance
des programmes de recherche une relance
de la vocation de recherche des équipes
médicales françaises ça va pas se faire
ni d'un claquement de doigts ni en
quelques semaines et encore moins en
quelques mois donc c'est plusieurs
années d'efforts et d'investissements de
long terme effectivement qui permettront
peut-être que dans une prochaine
décennie et bien là c'est là la france
figure différemment on n'est pas le
marais scientifique merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir participé à ce débat tient cette
dernière minute qui concerne les les
mesures de restrictions aux frontières
le président américain joe biden qui
annonce qu'il n'y a pas lieu à ce stade
de prendre de nouvelles restrictions aux
voyages concernant le sol américain
merci encore à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat sens public continue nora